i wonder if this has something to do
with just sort of sociosexual
orientation of you know whoever whoever
happens to be expanding the beliefs so
if you tend to be a person who's had
your heart broken or had a lot of
negative interactions maybe you had the
expectation of monogamy and then you
sort of have one too many negative
experiences then you may start to be
very preoccupied with uh with the issue
of concern i think that's exactly what
happens i i think that so you know we
talked about people being shielded from
the consequences of their luxury beliefs
and they're shielded to some degree
right but my suspicions are is that the
relationship between sex and emotional
intimacy is a lot tighter than people
want to presuppose when they
insist that all forms of sexual
expression are laudable it's just not
the case emotionally
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to be
able to speak with rob henderson he's a
phd student in evolutionary and social
psychology and gates cambridge scholar
at the university of cambridge he
received his bachelor's degree in
science in psychology from yale and is a
veteran of the u.s air force
his writing has appeared in the new york
times the wall street journal and
colette among other outlets he is
currently writing a memoir tentatively
titled troubled a memoir of foster care
family and social class to be published
in late 2022 by gallery books a division
of simon schuster
he is possibly best known for the idea
of luxury beliefs which is where i first
came across them first published in the
new york post in short form and then in
longer form in colette thanks very much
for agreeing to talk to me today rob
it's a pleasure to have you here
it's great to be here dr peterson thank
you no problem so let's talk first of
all about luxury beliefs and exactly
what that means and how you came
uh come up with the idea and
what the consequence of disseminating it
has been
yes so the luxury beliefs idea
i define as ideas and opinions that
confer status on the upper class while
often inflicting costs on the lower
social classes
and i mean there are multiple strands to
this idea but it originally started with
my observations in undergrad at yale um
so as you said you know currently i'm a
grad student at cambridge before this i
was a student at yale but before that my
life was a lot different i grew up in
foster homes in la
later i was adopted into a working class
town in northern california serving the
military so i just had a completely
different
set of life experiences and background
than many of my peers
at this ivy league university
and
in that new york post essay the
the original luxury beliefs essay i
opened with this story of uh this
conversation i had with a classmate of
mine in undergrad
uh we're sort of talking about
relationships and career and she said to
me you know i just think monogamy is
outdated i just think it's you know not
really good for society i think it's
just this sort of old patriarchal way of
thinking
and i'd heard things like this before
but this time i asked her um
well what do you plan to do you know
what do you want to do with with your
own life and with your own relationship
situation and so on in the future and
she herself said well i'd like to get
married and settle down and have a
family at some point you know sort of
after my career takes off and i asked
her what was your life like before that
you know how did you grow up and
essentially she had come from a very
stable intact to parent family
and so
this
puzzled me because this was uh
emblematic of so many of the opinions
i'd heard of my uh in undergrad from my
peers they would say one thing they
would believe this one set of
interesting or unusual beliefs that i'd
never heard before from anyone else uh
but then they themselves had come from
sort of more conventional uh
upbringings
and they themselves planned to have that
kind of life that sort of uh more stable
traditional family i'd once heard
someone put this way that um you know a
lot of sort of affluent
people they uh what is it they walk the
50s and talk the 60s and i wondered you
know what's going on here
um
and so while i was an undergrad i came
across a series of papers series of
ideas both from psychology and sociology
so these sort of sociological aspects um
i drew this from thorsten vablin
and vaden's idea you know he wrote the
theory the leisure class in the late
19th century and he basically said that
you know the elites of his day they
broadcast their status with their
material goods with you know expensive
clothes tuxedos uh evening gowns they
take up these very uh expensive and
time-consuming hobbies like golf or
beagling
and all of this is to basically indicate
their high social position and you know
some people say this book was written
sort of tongue-in-cheek but i think
there's a lot of truth to this
now if we fast forward to the modern day
uh i think it's there are two things
going on with why it's not actually
fashionable anymore to display your
status with luxury goods with material
goods
number one i think it's become viewed as
kind of gauche if you walk around an ivy
league campus today the students don't
look like they don't have the iv look of
like the 1950s or 1960s they kind of
just look like regular college students
number one
and i mean this is true pretty much
anywhere if you look at very wealthy
people and the famous example of this
would be mark zuckerberg wearing cargo
shorts and a hoodie it's just not that
cool anymore to
wear clothes that indicate that your
high social status
the other thing is material goods have
become more affordable
um you know even my sort of poor and
working class friends back home all of
them have iphones um you know maybe of
course like their life
aren't as comfortable as my peers in
college but a lot of material goods have
become so affordable that it's become
harder to stand out in that way yeah you
so reflected i think to some degree in
the decline in burglary
all right material objects just aren't
as worth as much as they were and so
they don't distinguish between people
anymore
it's not worth it anymore uh to steal
things
and and so so that's uh that's the
aspect of it that led me to think okay
well
first of all you know luxury goods are
not being displayed as much by the upper
class but i still think it still seems
to me they care very much about social
status and this is where the psychology
aspect of it comes in
from a researcher named cameron anderson
at uc berkeley he's a psychologist who
found
he and his colleagues found that
basically
the upper class cares the most about
social status
they care the most about obtaining it
and they care the most about preserving
it which at first i thought was a bit
counter-intuitive i thought that perhaps
the the most downtrodden
the kind of uh people who are in the
lowest strengths of society we care the
most about obtaining money and wealth
and status but that's actually not true
it's the people who are already at the
top who care the most about it and
that's really what i saw at yale 2 uh
where you know these people were very
much they were strivers um they were
very interested in pursuing status do
you suppose that's a partial consequence
of the fact that failure is perhaps more
painful than success is rewarding
so once you have it
let's say you have high social status
you're very much inclined to keep it
because the alternative would be so
i suppose in some sense unthinkable so
catastrophic for you
right so so this is the the idea of
almost like this prospect theory idea
that when you have it it hurts twice as
much as obtaining it i think there is
something to this idea um i noticed
there was a lot of anxiety
uh among many of my peers uh
this feeling that they have to keep up
they have to constantly strive they have
to get on to the next goal
and i think what exacerbates this
feeling is that they're surrounded by
people just like them uh it was it was a
bit
unlike
my own experience
when i had got into undergrad
i um
i thought like okay so i'm okay i got
into college like that was my goal i
never thought i was ever going to get
into college and so when i got there i
thought like oh i'm okay
and then i saw that these people didn't
feel okay that they had to get the next
internship they had to get into law
school they had to do this they had to
do that
and i think a lot of it is because
they're around people they've grown up
around those kinds of people their
entire life
and
so
there's this belief like it was
inevitable like they always had to do
this there was never a question of their
success right right for me it wasn't
like that yeah well it wasn't all this
pressure when i taught at in boston at
harvard i mean one of the things i
noticed was that the students there were
you know they were pleased to be at
harvard there was no doubt about that
but they it was extremely competitive
implicitly
and i suppose that's part of the
consequence of it being essentially
based
as as much as it could be on
on competitive merit
and so it was also the case that many of
these students had been outstanding
where they had come from they were class
valedictorians and usually had at least
one or two other major accomplishments
under their belt but then when they got
to these intensely selected institutes
they were also in some sense average
instantly and below average in many ways
because you know no matter how smart you
are the probability that you're the
smartest person in your class at harvard
is pretty damn low
and so
the implicit level of competition was
extremely high
and so that might also exacerbate the
sort of tendencies that you're
describing and people tend to compare
themselves to their immediate peers not
to the broader world
right
and and and this is part of why i think
is is is driving this um you know i make
this this point in the essay that
they're they're dunbar's number you know
they're the 150 closest people to them
are
large part have reattached or they sort
of detached status to goods and
reattached it to beliefs
uh and this was driven by my you know
sort of what i saw where i heard
opinions and ideas that i had never
heard anywhere else i mean probably the
most you know contentious uh recent
example of what uh of a luxury belief is
this idea of abolishing the police
um
to me this is so emblematic of
you know very comfortable highly
affluent educated people who would never
have to bear the cost of of what that
policy would entail and yet they're
propounding it they're you know they're
they're broadcasting it and promoting it
uh with the knowledge that this is going
to make them look good to their peers
it's going to make them look uh
progressive and interesting and
provocative and win them all these
social points from their social circle
uh without really giving much thought to
what would happen to the poorest among
us
and yeah
one of the things that always struck me
about
beliefs in
progressive so-called progressive causes
among high status individuals or those
who are about to be high status
individuals which would typify everyone
in an ivy league university i mean if
they're not high economic status at the
present time they certainly will be by
all likelihood by the time they're 30 or
40. so they're already part of the upper
class regardless of their claims
they seem to want to have it both ways
they want to be members of the most
privileged class and then also be
rewarded
for
their ally ship let's say with the
oppressed and so they get to be rich and
privileged and friend to the oppressed
at the same time which always seemed to
me to be a form of of
of greed rather than
sympathy rather than genuine sympathy
there's not much self-sacrifice involved
in the adoption of the beliefs that you
just described and what i don't remember
who said it when the
upper class catches a cold the lower
class gets pneumonia
and so
these destabilizing beliefs are a lot
harder on people at the bottom of the
socioeconomic structure than they are
for people at the top who as you said
tend
to get married disproportionately often
compared to people who are lower down on
the socioeconomic structure
yeah there's uh there's sort of this
sinister theme that i saw sometimes uh
where
i would see students for example say um
that investment banks are emblematic of
capitalist oppression
and then i would see those same exact
students attending recruitment sessions
for goldman sachs
um and
my interpretation of what they were
doing here
is basically they were trying to
undercut their rivals they were trying
to undercut their competition so
uh if you and i are students and i can
convince you that investment banks are
evil don't work there that's one less
competitor that i have in my quest to
the top
uh some people have told me that this is
too cynical
i used to think that i don't know as
time goes on most likely yeah well i was
struck too at
harvard by
the disproportionate movement of
harvard undergraduates into financial
services
so
i didn't understand until i went to the
united states and worked at that
extraordinarily powerful university what
a staggering proportion of the students
end up in jobs exactly like that and
they are
considered
very broadly i would say among the
undergraduates as the highest status
jobs they certainly have tremendously
high starting salaries and
i mean
harvard produced comparatively few
scientists let's say
so
yeah i noticed this uh i mean it's i've
seen the data on this something like 30
of of undergrads at places like harvard
yale and princeton
at least 30 it might be closer to 40
percent end up working in either
investment banking
finance or i think tech is the the third
most popular
right and they end up being often being
consultants and so forth so and fair
enough i mean they're high cognitive
ability individuals generally and so
it's not surprising that they vie and
they're competitive for the reasons that
you described in other reasons there's
powerful socialization at work too
so it's not surprising that they
gravitate towards those jobs but then i
suppose to what degree do you think
beliefs of this sort are also motivated
by guilt
i mean i've often i've often seen you
know in the united states in particular
more well-to-do people tend to put their
children in private schools
and i think there's a tremendous amount
of guilt about that because they are
well they are racially segregated
comparatively speaking
at least along some dimensions and and
that's a really not an egalitarian thing
to do even though you may be motivated
to provide whatever advantage you can
for your children
so
is it guilt as well as the broadcasting
of status in your opinion
i i don't know i think that there's a
lot of um
performative guilt it seems like they
talk a lot about guilt but when it comes
to actually paying any kind of personal
cost i really don't see
their their behaviors aligning with
their luxury beliefs uh like you said
they they're willing to shell out all
this money for private schools they're
willing to pay money to live in secure
neighborhoods there was a story last
year sort of at the height of the uh the
pandemic
in addition to a lot of the protests and
the rights that were going on in
manhattan a lot of rich new yorkers fled
to the hamptons and they had hired
private security
um
and you know that's
that's perfectly sensible i mean i
understand why they would do that but
this is sort of the the actions of of
the affluent that they take um
the broadcast one set of beliefs but
then privately they'll do everything
they can to secure the their safety and
the future of their their children
so maybe it's guilt but i'm not sure how
how genuine it is um
i mean i i just saw like i mean there's
so many examples of these luxury beliefs
that i saw uh you know from like i said
the the police issue
to uh the like open borders
to uh decriminalization of drugs i mean
all of these uh
these issues i think
are
disproportionately harmful to
working class lower class people
and there's there's no
cost no actual maybe there's guilt but
there's no actual uh uh sort of
costly uh benefit or costly extraction
well it also may be that when you're
relatively have been relatively
protected
but implicitly let's say okay so
you live in a gated community you live
among wealthy people you live in a
neighborhood where crime is essentially
non-existent
where privation is essentially
non-existent all of these things
then
the cost of
order provision seems disproportionately
high because you have no idea what it's
good for
and so you can imagine that you might
also be inclined to only look at the
negative side of
well drug criminalization and police
funding and all of that because
it doesn't appear in your world that
there's a necessity for those things
so if you've lived your whole life so
comfortably and you've never experienced
any kind of hardship or any serious
hardship then a lot of this is taken for
granted well at least not of the not the
kind of hardship i mean it's not like
people who are well-off don't still have
hardship because their families get sick
and there's still all sorts of but
they're protected very well from social
unrest let's say
and so the means necessary to ensure
that
society remains at peace the enforcement
reasons for example and that would
include border protection
seem exclusionary and unnecessary when
they've never been a threat of any sort
at all
yes i mean
even beyond the physical safety issue
um
one one other interesting example of
this phenomenon i think is
a lot of people in tech these sort of
tech tycoons will
sort of promote the benefits of
addictive technology while privately
they uh go on these sort of dopamine
fasts they don't use this technology
steve jobs famously would not let his
kids use an ipad
um a lot of other
people in tech reportedly tell their
nannies to carefully monitor how much
their children use smartphones and so on
there are tv personalities who own
television networks but they don't have
a tv at home
and a lot of this i think is sort of
like you know don't get high on your own
supply uh you know addictive technology
is okay for the masses all of you can
sort of get sucked into these screens
but i'm going to be very careful with
how me and my children and my family
interact with this technology that i'm
getting rich off of
so it goes even beyond the sort of
physical security i think it's more even
more so about
um
you know you're taking care of yourself
while not so much thinking about the
harmful effects on on others
yeah so it's a matter of wanting to have
it both ways and so what what would you
consider
what is the universe of luxury beliefs
like uh
well i would say that luxury beliefs are
are primarily situated of course uh
among highly educated affluent people
and essentially i mean there's
i suppose you know i'm not keeping this
compendium at least not yet of every
luxury belief that exists but
essentially um if someone of a high
social position expresses a belief i
think it's important for anyone who
holds any kind of influential position
in society to think about well what are
the consequences of if that belief were
to be implemented and especially when it
trickles down um
it's one of the effects
yeah well i mean conservatives are
always concerned with unintended
consequences right and so they don't
presume that hypothetically benevolent
social policies are going to produce a
positive result
sure and and i think there's there are
social patterns that that uh give reason
for for concern so for example um
the this idea of sexual promiscuity i
think the the latest manifestation of
this is is polyamory um i had this
conversation with a friend of mine uh
you know a couple years ago he uh told
me you know rob when i when i opened up
my my tinder app you know this dating
app uh and i i put the radius to just a
couple of miles around you know he also
attends you know a university when i
when i put it just to a couple miles
around
um you know it's pretty much all of my
matches all of the other profiles i see
are other other women students at the
university
and when i look at their bios
half of them say that they're
polyamorous or they're interested in an
open relationship or they're not looking
for anything too serious
and then he told me when he extended the
radius to match with women outside of
the university uh
into the town which is um you know sort
of this working-class town
uh he said that about half of the women
that he he saw on on his app were single
moms
and
so and it's the same age group right
like 18 to say 23 years old so in the
university they're interested in having
fun and then the 18 to 23 year old
working class women are having a much
different experience of life
and my claim is that the luxury beliefs
of the former have basically trickled
down and wrecked havoc among the latter
so starting in the 1960s
there's data from robert putnam and
charles murray and others which you may
have seen showing for example that in
uh working children born to working
class families and children born to
affluent families 95 of them were uh
born and raised by both of their birth
parents
and if you fast forward from 1960 to
uh the affluent families the children of
the affluent
uh had dipped slightly so it was 95 in
1960 and by 2005 it had dropped to 85
percent so it was a slight drop but by
and large still overwhelmingly uh intact
families and for the working class again
in 1960 was 95 and by 2005 it had
dropped to 30 percent so a completely
different world
too because there's an interesting
progression
between different ethnicities and races
along that curve so the first correct me
if i'm wrong but i believe this to be
the case the first population that
really affected was the black population
then it was the hispanic population
then it was the the white population but
the curves match they're just um
they're just like 10 years apart
if you if you look at the same
socioeconomic level and so yeah that's a
good example of
policies that are hypothetically liberal
at the high end having a devastating
effect
farther down
and you know these people who it's
people who claim that marriage for
example is a patriarchal institution
well the best rejoinder to that i know
of is then well why do the rich get
married and the poor don't
they choosing to oppress themselves
given their options
it doesn't make any sense i mean i think
it's an absolutely foolish theory to
begin with but
but
that seems to me to be a piece of data
that indicates quite clearly that if you
have a choice
that's what you pick or if you have the
widest possible level of choices that's
what you choose
and so yeah it's a it's a catastrophe
although you know that's that the fact
that it's a catastrophe is also hidden
by a whole other set of luxury beliefs
like
all families are of equal value
which in some sense is true
right because if if you're thinking
about
how each person should be valued and
whether or not
the child of a single mother should be
valued well obviously the answer to that
is yes but that doesn't mean that all
family configurations are equally
functional
on average
and i think the data is absolutely clear
that children with intact to parent
families do far better now if you get
divorced there are things you can do
that moderate the effect of the divorce
what's his name
he wrote the boy crisis
warren farrell has documented farrell
has documented a number of ways that
people who get divorced can
ensure that their children
do about as well as they would in an
intact family and some of that involves
approximately 50 percent contact with
each parent
i think the parents also need to attend
counseling
third party counseling so that they can
maintain a reasonable relationship and
they have to live within
something approximating a 20-minute
drive from one another
something like that but i mean that
takes a lot of balancing and dancing to
replicate that environment and it seems
impossible in our society to have us
discussion about the fact that
some forms of families
are
better for children than others
and because we think of any imposition
of a value analysis of that sort as
discriminatory and you know in some
sense it is discriminatory because when
you say that one thing is better you're
also saying at the same time that the
opposite of that is worse
well then it depends on who you're
trying to focus on and well i i go by
the data fundamentally and
you know children born to young single
mothers especially if the young single
mothers are troubled and therefore also
easy targets for predatory males
they don't do well and there's
multi-generational effects of that and
we're too bloody
naive and
and
i don't know
immature
i guess
to have a serious conversation about
such things and we also don't know how
to put the genie back in the bottle
but there's no tax break for example for
stable married couples
so there's no economic policy that
supports it
yeah i i mean
i i'm not entirely
sure that that would even change
much i mean i think this is much more of
a cultural issue than an economic issue
i mean you know a lot of people say well
the reason well it's kind of interesting
how how many different excuses are
produced for this i mean like you said a
lot of people say that it's this
patriarchal institution but then why are
the rich getting married more than the
poor well i don't know and then a lot of
people
let let's talk about that for a minute i
mean
sure
i suppose that claim is grounded in the
historical
interpretation that
in the past
women were treated in some sense
as the equivalent of property
and
now whether or not that's a reasonable
interpretation of the past is entirely
up for debate although we could say that
it was more true 150 years ago than it
is now but we could also point out that
birth control was a lot less
reliable
yeah and so the relationships between
men and well and women didn't have the
freedom they have today for all sorts of
reasons hygienic reasons for that matter
i mean one of the things that freed
women was the easy access to
technology that dealt with menstrual
cycle
and public toilets and all of that i
mean we just don't understand how much
sanitary technology for example is built
into the infrastructure
as well as safety
because women can walk down the street
unaccompanied without any problem
comparatively speaking we don't
understand how much of that has changed
the relationship between the sexes
and so
there may have been property-like
associations with marriage 150 years ago
but first of all that doesn't
necessarily mean that that was a
patriarchal institution
i mean it was still the case that the
idea was that the men would stick around
and provide economic support and care
for the children and that's a long-term
binding contract and it seems to me the
obvious opposite in some sense of
libertine freedom
so where's the patriarchy in that
precisely
i mean women weren't equal in some sense
but
there are reasons for that
i mean many people have made the
argument that by loosening the norms
around marriage it's actually been to
the benefit of of men
in some sense you know to be able to
have lots of promiscuous partners with
many different women and perhaps
impregnate some of them and not have to
stick around there's no obligation to
them beyond maybe producing childhood
that means that it's
advantageous to psychopathic men
right darker bad types well exactly
because you know the hallmark of
psychopathy is
short-term advantage
taken by a given individual without care
for anyone else
and it certainly seems to me like dating
apps like tinder now i don't i don't
want to call every male who's successful
on tinder a psychopath i'm not saying
that but i would say that it isn't
obvious to me at all that
if you're a successful polyamorous male
on tinder and so that's going to be a
very tiny subset of men
that are hyper selected by women a tiny
subset of men
who who receive almost no rejection
they're set up to learn to be
psychopathic because
all their
interactions with other people can be
devoted to short-term sexual
gratification with no emotional intimacy
or long-term
commitment
and that's a hell of a training ground
as far as i'm concerned that's that i
mean it depends on what you want for a
society but
as you said even the affluent women who
profess
a desire for polyamory which is complete
bloody rubbish in my estimation and
completely underestimates the economic
consequences of sex they still dream of
the fairy tale princess who meets the
prince who you know wakes her up with a
kiss and and they're married happily
ever after so it's it's such bloody
nonsense we allow our culture to be run
by the pathetic fantasies of immature
adolescent
delusion fundamentally as far as i can
tell
there was a study i saw um
i think it was last year on on this very
question of of who uses dating apps and
sort of their personality traits and so
on and they did indeed find and these
these were just university students
which you know take it for what it's
worth but the uh uh the people who are
using the dating apps which is about
one-third of the the students uh in in
the sample pool the they were um sort of
more likely to be interested in
short-term sexual conquest not really
surprised more uh more interested and
more likely to use drugs and alcohol
more likely to have sort of callous
sexual attitudes i can't remember the
exact term they used for this for this
construct but basically they were more
likely to agree with statements like sex
is like a game where one person wins and
the other person loses so if you're
using a dating app you're more likely to
say uh yes to that kind of question so
in a way
status element to that i mean there's
the old trope of notches in the bed
frame and
among adolescent competitive adolescent
males there's no reason
there's every reason to be competitive
about how much you can drink and how
many people you can lure into bed i mean
even if you don't necessarily believe
that personally you know at a deep level
and maybe you suffer for it emotionally
to some degree even though you might
obscure that from yourself it's
certainly something to score points with
with your peers
and there's plenty of that kind of you
know that competitive bantering
in in adolescent especially adolescent
male culture and i mean it's not
surprising to some degree because
adolescent males have to figure out how
to
navigate the sexual landscape and
they're going to do that in all sorts of
awkward and
finely unproductive ways it's not an
easy thing to bind or to regulate
properly but
i mean these technologies like tinder
tinder is a transformative technology
and it's radically underestimated in
terms of its potency because
it
produces
hyper-successful predatory males and
reduces rejection it eliminates
rejection because i mean you can be
totally rejected in which case you're a
failure on tinder but
in normal
pre-mating interaction let's say there's
a high probability of rejection
especially on the part of males
and that text well there's actually
research on this yes
on tinder uh yes uh
so there's there's research basically
showing this so on tinder uh
women are they they like you know swipe
right they like the profiles of only
four percent of the men that they see on
the app whereas for for uh men when they
see female profiles they swipe right or
like uh more than sixty percent that six
zero sixty percent of the profiles right
so that's really worth concentrating on
because that's a great example of
hypergamy
right so women mate across and up
success hierarchies
and men mate across and down
right so and women like men who are
about four years older
cross-culturally
they like men who manifest signs of
success as well as being handsome and
personable in all of that and the reason
for that as far as i can tell is that
they're looking to
equalize
the economic disparity that exists
because women
take a harder hit from sex and pregnancy
than men
so they're looking to equalize that and
no wonder they're looking for someone
who's competent
this is for long-term media who's
competent and generous
right you want both of those so
competence would be intelligence general
cognitive ability and the markers that
go along with that they want
conscientiousness or openness as well as
other desirable personality traits and
they want generosity honesty all of
those but so they're looking for someone
who can provide well it's not because
they're greedy precisely it's because
well they're going to put themselves in
a more vulnerable position if they have
a child and we know this because even
affluent women who have a child by
themselves or who get divorced tend to
drop down the socioeconomic hierarchy a
fair bit which is of course why alimony
payments and all of that are necessary
so this hypergamy means women are much
more selective in their mating than men
are and that's true cross-culturally and
it's not surprising because they pay a
bigger price for sex it's more dangerous
for women because they can get pregnant
and it might be more dangerous
emotionally as well and i believe that
would be a reflection of their higher
levels of agreeableness and higher
levels of negative emotionality so women
do put themselves at risk more and that
might be why there's such a
intense debate about what constitutes
can't consent on campuses despite these
beliefs in polyamory and all of these
things but so anyways on tinder as you
said women select four percent of the
men
yes so that means i would imagine that
four percent is very high up on what
you're calling into the success
hierarchy i have a friend a good looking
guy
uh he was very active on tinder for a
while and he accumulated more than
twenty thousand matches on the app
twenty thousand
twenty thousand and he was so successful
that tinder
uh pinpointed him early on and uh gave
him all kinds of free perks and bonuses
and lifted his radius restrictions gave
him the
the tinder gold app or whatever version
of it basically trying to
continue to use the app
yeah
they wanted to entice him this is so
amazing they never want you to leave
these are unbelievably pernicious and
vicious broad-scale social experiments
that are far more potent than anything
like government policy
you know i mean
he's in genghis khan territory
with 20 000. i don't know i mean it's
really
twenty thousand yeah well my suspicions
are he tried
and i i know he'll get a kick out of
that that records for for like me
athletes for example and movie stars
there's some of the men have reportedly
slept with thousands of women yes wilt
chamberlain and
um there's others who who are in the
same category but they're people they're
men who have women throwing themselves
at them all the time lining up for them
and and i've read biographies of people
who had that sort of thing happen as
well but that's not the typical male
experience i know the typical male
experience is all rejection
exactly right they might get a couple
matches a week
right right so while so you see what's
happening is that tinder is one of the
forces that's transforming monogamy into
polygamy and the problem with polygamy
is that it it follows a pareto
distribution like the distribution of
wealth is that some tiny minority of men
get all the sexual opportunity and all
the rest get virtually none and that is
a recipe for for social instability i
mean that that sort of deregulation
of romantic relationships you know
whereas in the past it was expected for
you to have one partner and over time
settle down whereas now it's
a total free-for-all i mean there are
aspects to this that a lot of people
don't think about i mean i talk to young
people so i have younger friends who who
i talk to who are sort of very active on
on the apps and then sort of the dating
scene and they'll tell me things like
it's it's even easier to cheat so in the
past if you wanted to be unfaithful to
your partner it was risky because you
know essentially like you you had the
same social circle you had the same
friends everyone knew everyone else but
now with the apps you can match with
someone who is completely outside of
your social reality outside of your
partner's social reality you can have a
very discreet rendezvous no one will
ever know about this
um ghosting has become more common i
don't know if you about ghosting but
it's basically where you're in a
relationship with someone
um and after you have sex you know once
or however many times then you just
vanish you never see that person again
uh delete you know delete them from your
phone block them on social media you
never have to see them again and there's
no social cost to this that's a real
psychopathic conquest strategy yes
right yeah because the psychopaths they
tend to form relationships that are very
um predatory and then disappear
because that way their reputations stay
intact as long as they can continue to
disappear
but i'm interested in what you had said
before about whether this is actually
sort of cultivating psychopathy in young
people and young men where you know in
the in the past you know typically a
psychopath would do that on their own
but now with the apps and the technology
removing all of the friction from
you know breaking up with someone or
having to communicate with someone that
you no longer want to see them
i think a lot of people who who ghost
others they're not even thinking in
those terms they're not thinking i want
to maliciously hurt this person or i
don't care about this person it's just
it's like it's easy you know you press a
few buttons on your smartphone and you
can move on to the next conquest
um and i think a lot of people wouldn't
act that way otherwise well the question
would be what happens to you after you
do that four or five times you know
let's say you're not particularly
psychopathic to begin with it's like you
you you learn what you practice
and i would say look if if you're using
people continually as a means to an end
and i think sex is probably the most
effective way of doing that
then
you're establishing a pattern of
interaction between you and other people
at perhaps the deepest possible level
and so if you do that repeatedly
first of all you're not you're certainly
not engaging in anything that might be
regarded as a as a meaningful or deep
relationship
quite the contrary you regard that as
excess baggage that's an impediment to
your next conquest so to speak
so
how would that not
i mean it'd be now you said there was
research on tinder has there been
research on the relationship between the
dark triad and these hyper successful
men
well i've seen research on dark triad
and tinder use and you know people who
are high on dark triad do tend to be
more successful accumulate more partners
uh specifically whether you know this is
related to gender and whether men are
more successful or or more likely to to
hurt others using these apps i haven't
seen anything on that i have
interestingly seen
um i think this was from pew
where they
broke down the data by
education level
and they asked people questions like
have you ever been harassed on this
dating app have you ever met someone on
a dating app who inflicted physical harm
on you
basically the wide variety of negative
experiences through using dating apps
and they found that people who are not
college graduates were far more likely
the women were far more likely to report
negative experiences on the dating apps
compared to
college educated women and to me this is
also indicative of this you know this
sort of social class divide
um another manifestation of the luxury
belief of sexual promiscuity where you
know you introduce these dating apps you
have no idea what's going to happen or
how this is going to warp society and
how people are going to interact in
romantic relationships and it's
disproportionately harming
uh lower educated lower income women who
are like you're saying they're probably
more likely to meet psychopaths they're
probably perhaps less adept in some ways
at screening for certain kinds of guys
the other thing is
because
well they're a lot more they're a lot
easier to prey upon i mean their
straights are a lot more desperate and
they've knocked themselves out of the
single girl dating market and lowered
their market value so to speak i hate to
speak of it in terms like that but it's
clearly the case because to initiate a
relationship with a woman who has a
child already is to initiate a
relationship that has a lot higher up
front cost the complexity of negotiating
the relationship with the child the
additional responsibility that has to be
taken on instantly and none of that's
the least bit trivial
so
so that means and we know that in
general if you
do a triangular imagine triangular
representation of a social hierarchy on
any valued dimension
the people who are at the lowest level
are those who are most susceptible to
any sort of uh destructive tendency that
comes whistling through they don't have
as much social support they're a lot
closer to abject poverty they don't have
the the broad social network or the
opportunities um so everything affects
them disproportionately including
epidemic illnesses and it's the case
throughout the
kingdom of life that low status
confers
vulnerability that's why people go for
higher status at least in part yeah so
right that the tinder
i mean
i don't know how widespread tinder use
is i don't know that much about tinder
but when i first found out about it i
thought this is a technology that while
they certainly named it properly because
tinder starts fires and it's a fire
starter and not just sexually and
something like 40 last i saw something
like 40 percent of people under 30 are
using the apps i would imagine it's
probably higher now
especially in the wake of covet so the
data that i saw when we collected i
think in 2019 but after covid and the
pandemic and the lockdowns
um there's no other way to meet people
so i'd imagine a lot more people
download those apps and we'll see if
they wean themselves off or if they're
hooked i mean these tech companies use
very
manipulative
strategies i talked to an executive i
won't say which dating app this was but
he told me that some dating apps
some dating apps will um basically what
they call i think they're called seating
where they'll put fake profiles of very
attractive usually women right because
men are are actually more likely to use
dating apps and they're sort of more
likely to pay for the premium profiles
compared to women who don't have to
because they're going to get matches
anyway um
so anyway the the dating app companies
they'll see them with fake attractive
women profiles and
intentionally match with men who have
recently downloaded a new profile who
basically newly created one and the idea
here is that if they if they download
the app and they immediately match with
an attractive woman uh and then they
usually have a couple of conversational
exchanges like hey how's it going good
how are you and then that's it the uh
the robot no longer responds to the user
but the reason why this is done is
basically to give them a little hit
right it gives them it's like
it's a major hit yeah yeah and so
basically they called it chasing the
dragon which is basically a term from
from from drug usage right from heroin
you give them a little hit and then
they're going to be chasing that high
for the rest of their lives so
you know i think that
there's so many complexities to this it
yeah it is and and
yeah they are uh creating
a lot of i think a lot of heartbreak and
a lot of frustration
over that
wow
if if you're interacting with someone
fake i mean that could be tailored to
your desire
be people i'd have all you'd have to do
is look at the pictures that someone was
looking at and produce a composite
that's a that's an amalgam of those
attractive
women let's say and
mean that the possibility for
manipulation is almost infinite and
you won't say which dating app that's
too bad because they deserve the
exposure but you know i i understand
your reticence that's really
unbelievably appalling and malevolent
well i will say that if if one app is
doing it then that means
more than likely they all are so it
almost doesn't even matter uh they're
probably all doing some version of that
because that's how they get users
right yeah well it's not that clever an
idea you know it's it's a pretty obvious
idea in a very crooked and horrible sort
of way
so
it's not like it would take a genius to
think it up
yeah
yeah and so so this idea of oh and i
wanted to go back so so this idea of um
differently educated women different
social classes having different
experiences on the dating apps well
they're also having entirely different
experiences in in the real world too in
terms of their dating and romantic
relationships after the erosion of
marriage
after the um sort of deteriorating
norms around
dating and romance
if you know i i talked to some people
from my hometown for example
and i think about you know the kinds of
guys who stayed behind who didn't go off
to college who didn't join the military
who just sort of languished and hung
around there
these are not you know just to put it
bluntly these are not uh it's not prince
charming
and so when women are dating these men
and there's no social norms no no forces
constraining them many of them act very
poorly
um you know a lot of alcoholism a lot of
drug use uh you know verbal and
sometimes physical abuse emotional abuse
um a lot of these guys who sort of are
not not so educated
don't have a lot of money not a lot of
life prospects when they get involved
with a woman they don't necessarily
treat her very well whereas you know in
the past i think that there were
stronger norms around how you're
supposed to treat the opposite sex and
how you're supposed to interact with
them date them what's expected of you
and so on i think with the
um sort of dissolution of expectations
has come a lot more
trouble for lower income young women
yeah hypothetically the ones that the
progressives are trying to do something
for
are removing this constraints of
patriarchal relationships for example
the question always is what flows in
when you remove the dikes right i mean
that's another problem i suppose in some
sense that's analogous to the
the protection of of social classes
many of these institutions that are so
casually criticized
we don't know what forces shaped them so
you know i've been pilloried in the
press repeatedly for pointing out that
um
normative monogamy
controls male aggression
now that it's amazing to me that i've
been slashed to ribbons for making that
case because i thought that was like
anthropology 101.
so you know there's two things that
every society needs to control and one
is female fecundity because of its high
cost and the other is male aggression
it's like well i thought everyone knew
that if they were even moderately
educated and well how do you control
that regulate it for everyone's interest
particularly for the interest of
children the answer seems to be the
imposition of monogamous norms
now people object well are people truly
monogamous and the answer is not if you
set up the environment to differentially
award hyper-successful polyamorous males
which is exactly what gender does and
there are societies where that's the
case where one man has a thousand wives
so to speak and 999 men have none
but those aren't societies that are
stable and those young men who have
nothing to do
find things to do
and they aren't necessarily the sorts of
things that you want them to be doing
because what the hell do they have to
lose
fundamentally
and it's not a good idea to
generate a society full of young men who
have very little to lose
so
i
and it is an appalling thing that the
privileged classes
are more likely to disparage marriage
let's say
and these ideas
trickle down over time they sort of
permeate throughout society because
elites affluent educated people wheel
disproportionate influence uh whether
it's through media pop culture fashion
do you know here's something cool yeah
so do you know that names
drift down the social hierarchy
huh
well so well so
uh
influential upper class people will
produce a name for their child
and then that name is gets popularized
all the way down the social hierarchy
until it becomes passe
and so and becomes more and more common
as it drifts down so this influence that
you're describing you can measure it
everywhere they're the fashion leaders
they're on the cutting edge and everyone
imitates
and so
yes
and i think that
so so you know of course like actual
fashion clothing of course the sort of
trendsetters and then it trickles down
to everyone else i i didn't i didn't
know this about names which is really
interesting but i think it it is also
for sort of
moral beliefs as well one idea that i've
sort of been playing with maybe this is
you know a little bit dangerous for me
to say but i've been thinking about this
you know who was championing
um
sort of
color blindness integration this idea
that you know we should treat everyone
on their merits and so on i mean
whatever 50 or 60 years ago this was a
very progressive idea and it was mostly
championed by highly educated people
more affluent people they also tended to
leave the abolitionist movement in the
u.s and so on
but more recently
uh things have changed so my idea here
is that in the past the elites had this
idea of color blindness over time that
idea trickled throughout society
such as such that now today if you talk
to a typical middle class or working
class
western person they do tend to basically
believe in color blindness um their
racial attitudes are basically like who
cares um
and it's not it's not an important thing
in their lives
and so now that the elites have spread
this belief how do they once again
distinguish themselves from the hoi
polloi
from those middle and working class
people they once again have to make race
an important feature of our social
reality um
so now i have to comment about your
theories there for a sec if you don't
mind
when
francis galton
150 years ago started studying
he thought about it as
excellence something like that i mean
some of the iq research came out of that
he started to measure people on a whole
variety of different dimensions but his
conception of of excellence of
superiority let's say
wasn't so much cognitive capacity
the more differentiated sorts of things
that we might measure today and
associate with some degree of value
conscientiousness creativity
intelligence galton who is an english
aristocrat which is the reason i'm
bringing this up
was at the forefront of that movement
and he believed like most english
aristocrats of his time that
england was a superior culture and that
english aristocrats were the hallmark of
english superiority right and so but
that superiority
was fundamentally i would say moral
that the superiority that was being
searched for wasn't economic exactly
that the economic superiority was an
indicator of the moral superiority
and so and that would be associated yes
yes so that would be associated with
something like moral purity
and and and associated with disgust now
george orwell talked about
because he was from
relatively higher social status i think
he was upper middle class but he said he
had a visceral distaste of the working
class
and he had to overcome that and he did
he worked in restaurants and he worked
in all sorts of jobs he went to war i
mean orwell strove to overcome that
visceral disgust
and disgust is the opposite of disgust
is purity and that's associated with a
kind of moral superiority and so one of
the things that your idea one of the
ideas that your concept brings up is the
notion that the central axis of social
hierarchy is something like assumed
moral superiority and everything else is
a marker of that including economic
wealth you know i have this economic
wealth because i deserve it that's an
indicator that i'm superior morally
and that would go along with the idea of
i think that would go along with the
idea of luxury belief
you need to distinguish yourself from
the contaminated lower classes
constantly
and there were reasons which is i think
with the past
you think that is what's going on
i do i think that that that drives in
large part the motivation to uh to
broadcast these beliefs is to
basically tell the world i'm not one of
the you know the the hoi polloi one of
the little people unwashed masses the
unwashed mashes and and so they're
they're telling us you know to society
at large and and in particular they're
telling their peers you know don't
mistake me for one of those people there
and so this is sort of what i'm getting
at with this idea that you know now that
now that the masses believe that race
should no longer be treated as a big
deal in society
if you're a member of the elite if you
say that you're you may be at risk of
being mistaken
for one of the masses and so now you
have to sort of reintroduce the
importance of race and ethnicity and so
on
and say that we you know you don't want
to be colorblind you want to sort of
highlight our differences and and so on
but this here is a luxury belief because
you know
you may be able to
sort of promote this sort of
racial divisions among highly educated
highly affluent people
and in all likelihood it's probably not
going to hurt you very much but if that
belief is reintroduced into society
where we should once again pay very
close attention to what skin color we
are or what race we are
that could create a lot of problems for
ordinary people well i think it is the
world problems already because well
because
look i think
one of the factors and i'm certainly not
alone in this although maybe i can
differentiate it a bit better
i think a big part of the reason that
trump was so attractive i saw this hat
in florida i've told this story before
it said trump 2021
trump 2020 yeah because [ __ ] you twice
and i thought yeah that's exactly right
it's because there's this perception on
the part of the working class perhaps
particularly among working-class males
and maybe even more particularly
among working-class white males
that the progressive types that
hypothetically stand for the oppressed
have nothing but contempt for them
and the attraction to trump was
yeah well here have some of this
i feel that um every once in a while
i'll go back to my to my hometown red
bluff california yeah and i'll talk to
people
and i can feel this you know like i'll
tell them i grew up here i'm you know
i'm sort of this is my hometown
and whenever it comes up so what do you
end up doing uh i'm honest and i say you
know i ended up going to yale or
cambridge or whatever but i i'm i'm
always very quick to follow it up with
but but i i enlisted in the military
this is sort of my protection of like i
was in the military before i did all
this other stuff because i can sense
like when i say go to yale there's this
sort of moment of awkward silence and i
can tell they're sort of updating their
view of me and probably not in a good
direction either
uh and so then when i follow it up with
but i enlisted and then sort of things
calm back down i had this experience a
couple years ago in a casino playing
cards uh in corning which is an even
more poor and small town in northern
california
uh and my sister had you know let it
slip to the dealer that i was a student
at yale and the dealer looked at me for
a second he's like what are you even
doing in here you know in the sense that
like number one why would you be
gambling in here if you go to a school
like that and then number two like it
sort of sounded like i'm not really sure
i want you to be in here
and i told him like you know hey i serve
in the military i just want to play some
cards let's you know let's just have a
good time and and he sort of let his
guard down at that point but i think
there is this um feeling among more
blue-collar working-class people that
you know the elites over there are they
look down on us they
view us in a certain way
they treat us like we're stupid or
backwards
or evil or racist or whatever
and really it's i mean it's just not
true um
that kind of disdain also just sort of
amplifies the divisions
and
that is something that i'm also trying
to highlight to elites as well i think
that there's been a lot of emphasis in
psychology
on the role of fear in promoting belief
but i think that
disdain contempt and disgust have been
under appreciated as
separating motivational
factors
yes
and
it's one thing if someone's afraid of
you
that's not exactly offensive
i mean you might regard it as
unfortunate but there's also a kind of
implicit
respect a little bit of dominance
exactly exactly
but if they're disgusted by you or
disdainful of you
that means that you're in the
contemptible
and rotting category essentially
and that's a lot bigger dagger aimed at
your heart than
than fear i mean would you rather be
shied away from or sneered at
right
right yeah right yeah yeah
i think this is this is part of what's
uh what's driving these these sort of
class divisions
um
that that the sort of working class and
lower class they feel this they feel
that there's this disdain for them on
the part of the upper class and this is
part of what i'm trying to highlight too
with this idea is to to basically say
that like there are these divisions
social class exists in america and this
is something that we need to be thinking
about whenever we broadcast these silly
beliefs that no one believes in and uh
what blows my mind is that you know the
data are freely available you can see
what
the majority of americans believe about
the police or voter id laws or drugs or
what have you
uh
and
the affluent just don't care very much
they're still going to broadcast their
very silly beliefs
um
i guess well it could even be
to take your hypothesis perhaps a step
further but perhaps you've already
thought this
up
it's a real marker of my status that i
can afford insane beliefs
look look how crazy i can be and still
survive
well it's yes is it
right exactly it's completely
significant
exactly it's exactly that it's that it's
like a peacock's tail i can laden myself
down with this palpable absurdity it has
no material effect whatsoever on my
continued existence
so the peacock is dragging around this
very heavy colorful set of tail feathers
and can still survive and
the sort of highly educated affluent
members of the side can drag around
these very expensive costly luxury
beliefs that clearly have no
correspondence to reality
and they can still survive well and they
have some correspondence to reality for
them because they can afford to
experiment with the beliefs without
immediately perishing
or without you know fatally compromising
their lives in most cases not all but in
most cases whereas if you're
farther down the chain and have less
protection you toy around with polyamory
and you end up as a single mother when
you're 18. that's the end of that
and so then you have the rest of your
life to think about well perhaps that
wasn't very wise but you know it's a
little late then
yeah well you can believe whatever you
want if you are a graduate of a top
university and you are economically
comfortable you can have whatever set of
beliefs you want
and in all likelihood you'll be just
fine
but
you know i i want to underline that
because you are the you know you are the
most sort of sealed from the
consequences of your beliefs you
actually
and at the same time you wield the most
influence in society it's very important
to understand if you have a belief and
you're trying to implement it into
policy or to uh sort of erode or create
new norms or whatever
just be very careful with what it is
that you're doing um you know you can
treat it as a game and gain status but
in the longer term this is going to hurt
um you know it's going to hurt a lot of
people it's going to hurt the very
people that supposedly we care the most
about
so what have been
the consequences for you of
being known for
this kind of theory you're a student at
cambridge you're in psychology
um you were an undergraduate at yale i
believe you were an undergraduate yale
were you an undergraduate when you wrote
your essay on luxury beliefs
no that was um during my first year here
at cambridge uh in 2019
um
you know it's been
it's been an interesting experience i
was a little bit nervous when i first
wrote it simply because of the way
things are going in universities i had a
very
um
sort of turbulent introduction
to
university life to campus life when i
first entered undergrad so this was in
the fall of 2015. it's kind of funny so
in 2015 so i had just gotten out of the
military in august i started class in
september and a couple weeks later um i
saw that jonathan height was giving a
talk on campus and i had just read his
book the righteous mind about moral
psychology which is an interest of mine
and i thought that that's what his talk
was going to be about but the entire
talk was basically about you know our
university is meant to
equip students with the ability to seek
truth or is it meant to keep them safe
and protect them and shelter them and so
on i went to this talk totally confused
because that is not what i expected him
to talk about that's not what i knew
height for i knew him for his research
his psychology research
um
right so i didn't really i hurdled the
coddling of the american mind as well
that hadn't come out until
next year the year after okay um
so i only knew heid as the author of the
righteous mind
and
i
i didn't have the context for what that
talk was about because i was basically
an outsider to
this kind of world of you know free
speech debates and you know what is the
purpose of a campus and all of this
stuff i was basically just like a dude
who felt lucky to get into this great
university
um
and then about what three weeks after
that uh
erica christakis
who was a faculty member at yale wrote
this infamous email
about
uh basically defending freedom of
expression uh the yale university
administration basically emailed the
students on halloween yes yes so they
basically told students that the
administration told students you know be
careful what you wear and all this stuff
and erica costas wrote a follow-up email
saying you know if you have a problem
with what people are wearing you should
talk to them you know it's important to
uphold freedom of expression and so on
and there was this entire campus
eruption
my first experience you know having seen
any kind of uh campus uh protests like
this before students coming together
there was this uh
very sort of dark undercurrent around
campus people were very afraid to to
speak out against what was happening um
and so that basically uh was my
introduction to
what uh college is like uh
and that has basically stayed with me
ever since it was very formative
experience for me to see what had
happened there the other thing is i mean
i i met with erica christofis later i
was interested in taking a class with
her she taught a class at yale called
the concept of the problem child uh
which is basically you know this idea of
of um you know sort of orphaned children
children who get into trouble and
mischief and so on in this sort of
history and psychology of all that and
you know naturally to me given my
background is a very interesting idea
i was wait listed for that class and i
was very disappointed to learn that she
stepped down from teaching she said that
yale is not a good climate for for
teaching anymore because yeah well it's
no pain
right exactly it doesn't take very many
mobbing experiences to do you in
yeah well i mean i i had met with her
and i met with nicholas her husband
later who was also targeted by the mob
and to see like like the way that the
students treated them called them every
name in the book demanded that they be
fired and so on and then to like you
know discover that they were very good
people uh in in their personal lives um
they had taken in foster kids of their
own and and helped them and so on and so
like to see this this clash between like
what the students were saying about them
and who they actually were uh
i mean it uh
you know sort of formed this this
cynical perspective that i still have
about what kind of people go to these
universities and what their intentions
are
um
but in any case to talk to you about too
in terms of your luxury beliefs so
you know we were talking we've talked
about two things in some sense we've
talked about luxury beliefs and we've
talked about sexual politics
i suppose right and so i there's a way
of bringing those together so
do you think there's have you look at
gender differences in luxury beliefs so
for example i
the universities especially the liberal
arts are now dominated by women
and that's not a trivial transformation
it's a fundamental transformation and
it i mean heights
coddling idea
is easily associated with you know an
excessive amount of dependence let's say
and so
if the maternal role is fundamentally
the sheltering of infants
which i think is a reasonable way of
looking at it
then well then what happens when that
becomes political i mean because we
don't know anything about women's
large-scale political behavior
because this is all new and so when you
have an institution that's essentially
oriented to young people
who could be regarded as children but
wouldn't have to be but could be
regarded as children
is the maternal expression that their
safety and security and emotional
well-being is paramount and then let's
take this a step further just to be
annoying and horrible
these are all women who are at their
peak age of fecundity
and you might say well what's happening
with all those maternal instincts
they're just gone all of a sudden i mean
many 19 year old girls i've talked to
many of them
believe that their career is going to be
the most important thing in their life
very few 30 year old women believe that
even if they have high-powered careers
because they tend to discover that
high-powered careers come at a
substantial cost
like 60 70 hour work weeks etc and so
that life might be best spent in the
bosom of family and friends and with
children etc that's where much of the
true value is and most women figure that
out by the time they're in their 30s
which is why high-powered law firms for
example have a hell of a time
retaining their extremely competent and
highly valuable women no one likes to
talk about this they wouldn't talk about
it in the law firms that i consulted for
many many of them all the women would
talk about it privately but never
publicly the discussion was always about
how the law firms weren't doing enough
to support women with their children and
all the women knew that wasn't true that
wasn't what was going on and the law
firms were bending over backwards to try
to accommodate them because they wanted
to keep their high-performing women for
obvious economic reasons
and so we have all these young women
in who dominate institutions now like
well especially the humanities and
liberal arts and universities
it's like well is that the reason that
security and safety and
the sanctity of the home this is a
community this is a home it's like no
that's not what a university is actually
but but that's what it could be so
what do you think of that and these are
discussions that no one will have
obviously
yeah yeah i'm sorry to put you on the
spot you can tell me to go to hell if
you want because you're probably already
in enough trouble but
no i mean i think it's an interesting
idea
uh
i'm just not entirely sure
if that's what's happening here i mean
maybe i guess it maybe it would depend
on the level of analysis we're talking
about here i mean i think at a more
proximate level so maybe at that
approximate level it's about sort of
gaining social status in your local
environment but perhaps there's sort of
this ultimate evolutionary level like
why is it that these are the steps now
that one must take to obtain social
status yeah yes maybe underlying that
are the evolutionary reasons well that's
exactly the question here well you also
might wonder
what messages do
women at the peak of their fertility
want to broadcast to the community
well to the men and to the women for
that matter
and it might be i'm a caring person
well well why why would you broadcast
that that specifically because we're
looking at all sorts of potential values
you could broadcast right
the luxury values that are selected
appear to be ones that are putatively
associated with compassion
i mean it tilts hard in that direction
and height has shown that because
liberal types and and and the luxury
values that you're describing seem to be
associated with progressive liberalism
tremendous amount of that is driven by
compassion and
lack of harm rather than more
conservative uh values let's say
well i did see this study fairly
recently i think mitch brown is a grad
student he was an author on this
basically showing that
broadcasting uh
moral values
uh
does sort of increase
attractiveness to others and i can't
exactly remember what the specifics were
but they were sort of involved around
social justice about caring for the
oppressed and the downtrodden and so on
and
i think the effect was was most
pronounced for men broadcasting these
views uh and women found this to be
particularly attractive um
but i i could imagine like it would go
the other way too although a lot of the
sort of evolutionary psych papers i've
seen on sort of mating psychology
it doesn't i mean men seem especially
young men seem most interested in in
appearance like far far more than any
other sort of uh personality or
behavioral uh dimension among the women
but it's possible i mean what you're
saying that maybe it's not so much about
um
you know trying to trying to
impress the man but maybe just the
community as a whole or or their fellow
peers it also might not be a matter of
impressing it might be a matter of
a particular form of orientation
taking a new target
i mean for for most of human history
women who were in between 19 and 25 had
infants
right
okay so now they don't okay so that
that's not like triv that's not a
trivial transformation that's a
fundamental earth-shaking
traumatic dramatic transformation
and so
we would expect that to have no
political impact whatsoever
yeah i i mean it's it does seem to me
that it it's unlikely that it would have
zero effect
um
i guess my question would be why now
then um
why would it i mean because women have
been going to university now for 50 plus
years um i think they've been the
majority dominate
well they've dominated i mean i think
they've tipped past 50 since i think the
early 90s
so why is it now that you know this i
mean perhaps
you know that's that's one ingredient is
sort of the uh the dominance of of women
on universities in addition to maybe
social media and a few other sort of
more recent uh inventions that have that
have spurred this on
yeah well there was definitely a spike
in politically correct beliefs of the
sort that you've described in the 90s
oh interesting right right i mean but
what seemed to happen then i think that
was when i was teaching in boston
it it bubbled up but then the economy
boomed so madly that people seem to be
preoccupied by other things for a long
period of time
so
and then it went kind of back
underground and i thought well maybe
we're done with that nonsense to some
degree but it certainly popped back up
more recently and also 30 years isn't
very long i mean we're looking at
massive demographic transformations in
the structure of our society we don't
understand i mean we already talked
about the effect of technology
of computer technology on on mating but
we certainly haven't talked about the
effect of
of relatively
um
accessible and effective birth control
technology and all of that we touched on
that but i mean these are huge changes
that we don't know anything about
i mean even the
the sort of birth control issue i mean
it's really interesting to see just like
how the how the the the discussion
around dating has changed so much i mean
i remember
you know reading things from the sort of
early 2010s like 2012 2013 about how
hookup culture was this great thing that
was liberating and i think more recently
people are now starting to question that
um about whether that's i mean educated
people questioning whether this is good
for society
and
yeah i i mean i've read this very
interesting
article a long form article in brookings
i can't remember the authors
specifically about reproduction
technology and how
essentially
this has given rise to in some ways to
to more broken homes and their reasoning
was that once um
once reproduction became a biological
choice for the mother then fatherhood
beca in a social choice for the man
simply because in the past if a woman
got pregnant there were all of these
norms in place uh for the man to
basically marry the woman you know these
sort of shotgun marriages the community
shamed the men into marrying the women
if you skipped out on the woman then you
were seen as a deadbeat and so on there
was a lot of taboo and shame around that
but
we don't even know what effect there is
socially for example
with the presumption that well if you
get pregnant it's your own fault because
the
reliable reproductive prevention
technology is at hand
you know and many women who get pregnant
have not taken the pill properly for
example and so i'm not saying that they
should be blamed for that i'm not saying
that what i am saying is that it opens
the door for attribution of
responsibility to the women and we don't
know what that effect has what effect
there is of that on social institutions
that is actually the argument if i
recall from this brookings article which
was that
you know not necessarily societal of it
wasn't like society suddenly said well
now if you get pregnant your fault
because of the pill it was more on a
local level um couples started to
believe this men started to believe it
um the neighborhood the community right
started to accept that you know if a man
has sex with a woman and she gets
pregnant the man can say to himself well
that's not my problem that's kind of
your fault because you know you have
this magical pill that can
whatever so i don't have to get involved
anymore and i think the the local
community and the social environment
sort of tacitly if not if not um sort of
openly but at least tacitly started to
accept this kind of logic this kind of
reasoning
and this basically allowed men to skip
out on their responsibility well it's
almost inevitable to accept it if you
accept the proposition that women now
have control over the reproductive
function
and we don't want to dm like i thought
the 20th century would be remembered for
three things
hydrogen bomb
computer chip
the pill
three bombs right the tree because i
mean there hasn't been a time in human
history where females had control over
the reproductive function it's a it's
it's the equivalent of almost the
equivalent of a new species in terms of
dramatic biological transformation
someone's going to someone's going to
edit that part out and turn
good luck to them it's not like i don't
feel bad for the women who are put in
this position i certainly do they have a
tremendous amount to contend with but
you know the the
the other thing that's quite interesting
is all of the debates about consent that
have emerged on campus
and exactly what constitutes consent i
mean because the the 60s hypothesis in
the wake of the pill was
well sex doesn't really matter so
you know any consent will do because
it's now become a trivial
endeavor
i mean that was the theory right it's
just sex well and aids put the blocks to
that theory very very rapidly and
and you know no one likes to talk about
this because there's many things we
don't like to talk about but the aids
virus mutated to take advantage of
promiscuity in a major way and so
promiscuity gener promiscuity
distributed aids and and contributed to
the manner in which it manifested itself
and so
sex turned out to be
as deep a dangerous force in multiple
dimensions apart from mere reproductive
um
you know danger the other sexually
transmitted disease were reasonably
controlled with antibiotics
so
i find it interesting that people are so
just reluctant to talk about the
importance of sex as an incentive i mean
there's a lot of discussion in society
for example about economic incentives
about jobs professions
economic and equality and so on but
there's not much talk about the the role
that sex plays i mean you know from the
sort of evolutionary perspective sex has
been around since before we were human
sex is still going to be around long
after humans have gone extinct like sex
is universal it's it's what drives every
single species but we i'm just surprised
at how often we overlook it as as an
incentive for behavior and how fast
things are changing in the realm of sex
i just saw this uh statistic
uh from the washington post showing that
from 2008 to 2018 the number of sex the
amount of sexlessness among men under
the age of 30 has doubled
so in 2008
15 of men under age 30 reported not
having sex in the past year and by 2018
it had doubled to about 30 percent and
for women it had it it increased
slightly it was something like
10 in 2008 to like 15 in 2018 so there
was an increase a slight increase but
for men it has doubled
to the point where about one in three
young men are reporting that they
haven't had sex in the past year which
is a very new thing
um despite the despite the media gaps
right despite the apps despite um even
more uh support supposedly for
um sexual freedom and for polyamory and
novel relationship arrangements and the
further sort of devaluing of of the
importance of sex
um more people are having less of it men
and women but especially young men yeah
well my understanding is that's damn
near epidemic in japan
so what's happening
a tremendous number of young men in
japan are falling into that category and
in fact this society has become
increasingly sexless even among young
people i mean that's reflected to some
degree in the declining birth rate but
now it's been a long time since i look
looked at the statistics but that's my
understanding and so
if it happened there it's not surprising
that it you know might happen here and
that might be a consequence too of this
emergent polygamy that we were
describing is that all the spoils are
going to a very few
few men of course there's also the
the also the effect of pornography which
is a
substitute
and
you know that's also
i don't know much about the literature
on pornography use
and the relationship between it and
and actual sexual activity
um i have read some ominous things about
the increase in failure to achieve
erections among young men
that at least in principle is a
consequence of pornography use but
um i don't know how reliable that is
data that that married men are more
likely to experience divorce
if they watch any amount of pornography
and it's sort of uh you know
the more the more pornography they use
the more likely they are to to get
divorced
um
i think that yeah this this is another i
mean this is a very recent invention too
sort of streaming digital pornography
um
i've heard that researchers are having
difficulty even studying this simply
because they can't really find a control
group they you know there's no young men
who don't watch porn
at least at least have never not been
exposed to it and so this is a very
difficult thing for them to even even
study well it's another
indication of the
emergence of polygamy
because it's virtual polygamy
we can have an unlimited number of
attractive sexual partners now it's all
virtual
right but but that as
that is a transformative technology
i mean there's more pictures of
of nude women in one day than anybody in
history would have ever seen in their
entire life
yeah and i and i see this uh you know
the the consequences of this how young
people interact now where
there's even these contests to see how
long they can go without
watching it almost like it's a game
um you know these sort of communities on
reddit or on social media where they'll
sort of try to
um go for a month or go for 90 days or
whatever without watching it um at first
i think it starts this game no fap and
they're trying to i think
you know on the one hand it's sort of a
game for them it's a contest but on the
other hand i think there is this
underlying you know beneath the sort of
joking around about it i think there is
this view that like this probably isn't
good for us and let's see if we can get
off of it let's see if we can stop
um
and
i i don't i don't see like how this
isn't changing people i mean i was i
feel very fortunate because i came of
age just before
uh you know sort of uh fast
internet and all of this stuff that
started taking off like right before
youtube all of this stuff and i can
imagine that if i was a i don't know if
i was 13 and all of this stuff had
existed today like i'm sure it would be
warping my brain in one way or another i
mean between between the internet
between social media and then of course
the digital porn and the endless images
um
i i don't know how like very young boys
are are dealing with this this new um
this new technology
well these are all
it's very difficult for society to
structure itself around monogamous norms
that took a lot of work
and
when that's taken apart it's not at all
obvious how to put it back together
so and it does appear that we're
seeing the consequences of that
the consent issue on campus i think is
extraordinarily interesting
because
it isn't what you would would have
expected it isn't what anybody predicted
right we thought with the relaxation of
sexual norms that there would be this
possibility that sex could become casual
and there is an insistence it's so
strange to watch and this is associated
with your luxury belief item our idea
on the one hand we have this
absolute insistence
by the progressive types essentially
especially that
any and all form of sexual expression is
not only acceptable but to be celebrated
no matter what the form is
and on the other hand we have this
insistence
that sex is so dangerous that the
culture is best conceptualized as a rape
culture and that every step of sexual
interaction between the young man and
the young woman needs to be documented
like formally and perhaps even in
writing because that has been proposed
at some universities and so there's this
perversity about the twin insistence
right it's
all forms of sexual expression are
laudable
and freeing yet it's so dangerous that
every bit of it has to be documented and
the fundamental orienting
structure is something like rape
i wonder if this has something to do
with just sort of sociosexual
orientation of you know whoever whoever
happens to be expanding the beliefs so
if you tend to be a person who's had
your heart broken or had a lot of
negative interactions maybe you had the
expectation of monogamy and then you
sort of have one too many negative
experiences then you may start to be
very preoccupied with uh with the issue
of concern i think that's exactly what
happens i i think that so you know we
talked about people being shielded from
the consequences of their luxury beliefs
and they're shielded to some degree
right but my suspicions are is that the
relationship between sex and emotional
intimacy is a lot tighter than people
want to presuppose when they
insist that all forms of sexual
expression are laudable
it's just not the case emotionally
and those people the ones who are who
are supporting or promoting the complete
sexual freedom they may just be sort of
less sensitive
to having negative sexual experiences
because like you're saying all of it is
fun all of it is free there's uh all of
it is laudable and so for them if they
have you know experience that someone
else might do as negative for them it's
just not a big deal and so this is why
they're they're promoting more of a more
open sexual
they could be high in openness say so
exploratory and low in agreeableness so
you know they're not as they're not as
so associated they're not as likely to
form
immediate
empathy i mean this itself may be
connected to your earlier question about
sort of the the the growth in the number
of female students on campus i mean
there's been interesting research from
uh so john berger i think i'm getting
his name right wrote a book called
datonomics where he goes uh he he
discusses at length the role that sex
ratios play
uh for social interactions for romantic
interactions and basically he found that
on campuses where there's uh
more women than there are men
uh there's much more hookup culture
women expect less of the men
they report that like basically feeling
despondent about their chances of
getting a boyfriend uh men on the other
hand seem to have a much more uh uh
enjoyable time uh they report having
more sexual partners feeling uh more
upbeat
feeling more hopeful having more hookups
and so on whereas on university campuses
like caltech where there tend to be more
men than women it's actually the reverse
where women are more likely to have a
boyfriend to be more satisfied with
their romantic situation
and so on and basically the the um i
mean and this has been documented in
across cultures in different cities
different societies and so on and
basically the idea is that when there's
a large number of women
and a scarcity of men women have to
compete
for
that small pool of men and they're more
willing to basically modify their
behavior in ways that men find appealing
which you know oftentimes is sort of
short-term casual sex
uh you know hookups um sort of very
casual situations whereas when the river
versus the case and there's a scarcity
of women in a large number of men then
men tend to modify their behaviors to be
more oriented toward long-term
relationships towards commitment and
emotional connection and so on
and so as universities
uh become more dominated by by women and
the sort of
sexual uh
so their satisfaction with the sexual
landscape declines then maybe this is
related to some of what we're seeing of
course maybe with consent and some of
these other social justice issues that
we're seeing that a lot of it may be
sort of driven by um sort of
dissatisfaction with the romantic
landscape and and the way that men are
behaving a sense of being exploited but
then i would be interested to know if in
those universities where there's a
relatively smaller proportion of men and
the men report being more satisfied i
wonder
if that's the median or the average
right because i would say that's the
average
you think so i because i was thinking
that in those situations it would still
be a relatively small minority of men
who are getting all the sexual attention
now it might be better to be the mean
well wouldn't that mean that the mean
satisfaction would be high whereas the
median might yes that is sorry yes
you're exactly right that's exactly
right okay so there'd be there'd be a
fair bit of variation around the mean as
well yeah right yeah i i would agree
with that i mean
there's there's a lot of like sort of
interesting findings i think this was a
study from mit which showed that like
something like half of the graduates of
mit male male graduates of mit graduate
as virgins and
um
i think that this this pattern has also
been found in other top universities as
well and
and so this probably goes to this idea
that a small number of the men at at
universities are accumulating uh more
well that would go along with the four
percent
rating four percent description of
tinder and so what happens is that where
there's a relatively small number of men
that competition between women becomes
incredibly intense but for a very small
fraction of the men and because those
men have endless short-term options
there's no satisfaction on the female
side with regard to anything past you
know a short-term casual relationship
i saw this really uh kind of amusing
study it was in pnas of um
this idea of sexy selfies and which
countries
uh in which countries are women most
likely to post sort of sexually
provocative image of themselves on the
internet and on social media
and
so the researchers you know they put
forth various hypotheses one of them was
maybe it's maybe it's patriarchy maybe
in cultures where uh women are treated
very poorly they feel like they have to
present themselves in a certain way very
sexually provocative poses and so on but
that's not what the researchers found
what they found was that in in countries
where um
uh income inequality tends to be high uh
that's when women are most likely to
post sexy selfies and their um their
conclusion here was that when women are
competing for a shrinking number of
highly successful men
um they're more likely to pose in
provocative ways on the internet in in
the hopes of capturing their attention
which is maybe what we're seeing on you
know on instagram and on on various
other social media apps where
um i think there is this this sort of
like i don't know tilting towards more
more and more
sort of pornographic adjacent content in
the hope of capturing uh more attention
and
so i think that a lot of a lot of what
we're seeing may be it may be due to
sort of this this overlooked topic of of
the sexual dynamics in society
so what's been the consequence for you
of having pursued this line of thought
we we started to touch on that but we
didn't touch on it that much
um
it hasn't been too bad um you know some
people have questioned me on this i've
had some somewhat nasty comments
uh from other graduate students here at
cambridge
um
social media stuff but it really hasn't
been that bad um
yeah i've actually met uh quite a number
of people who agree with me
and who are glad that someone is
speaking out about this issue
um i actually met um yeah a lot of
friends by by talking about this openly
i think that this is if this is just one
of those things where people are are
silent because they're afraid of the
reputational cause but when someone else
starts speaking out they feel more
comfortable sort of coming out of their
shell more and more and discussing it
i on the other hand i
you know i'm sort of reluctant to
continue uh along a career in academia
simply because of everything that i've
seen so i mentioned before what i saw at
yale with the christakisses um part of
the reason why i came to cambridge you
know there are many reasons but one of
the reasons why i came here was because
i thought it would be different i
thought that the um
sort of uh social mobbing and the sort
of student protests and i thought that
was kind maybe i hoped that it was an
american thing and i thought that well
maybe if i go to england things will be
calm maybe things aren't as political
over there and within a matter of months
two things happened one was you were
supposed to come here to be a research
fellow and then you were just invited
because of the student protests and then
two there was a young postdoc named noah
carl who was supposed to you know he's a
postdoc here and he was fired uh because
of student protests as well and so i
thought okay well i come over here
hoping to get away from that and it sort
of followed me over here so maybe maybe
this is a sign that uh i'm supposed to
be doing something else other than than
uh than remaining uh within within uh
the the academy so once i'm finished
with my phd i may have yeah i heard the
grapevine that uh
you know hypothetically i was disinvited
from cambridge because
a photograph was taken with me in new
zealand of someone wearing a
t-shirt that was critical of islam
but i learned through the grapevine that
the decision to disinvite me had been
taken before that and that was used as
an excuse and not at all
reliable source
yeah so stunning stunning so that all of
that it was very
costly and painful for me to undergo
that and
you know it's so peculiar because i was
going to cambridge hypothetically to
talk about biblical stories with you
know people at the divinity center there
and the biblical story
the lectures that i've done have been
very popular and in reasonably
influential and you know well received
by atheists and religious people alike
so it was a serious academic endeavor
and it was very
difficult to bear the
oprobrium let's say that was associated
with that
um
i understand that that you know things
have perhaps changed for the better with
regards to such decisions more recently
but
um it was shocking to me to to find out
that it was based on a lie
and yeah
my reputation you know it's it's it's
it's uh it's quite something so so where
are you in your phd program now
uh so
finishing up my third year i should have
one more year and then i will be
returning to the states don't know
exactly what i'll be doing but uh yeah
like i said probably probably not in a
university at that point yeah things
have changed uh yeah so much over the
last few years in terms of
the you know political correctness and
how reluctant people are to speak out
and
i think um
yeah i started to experience that at the
university of toronto i started to get
nervous about
talking about sex differences and
personality
you know when i was just i taught a
personality course and i published
papers on sex differences in personality
so it was actually an area of
specialization of mine and for years i
would lay out the data which was
somewhat
ethical i don't mean laying it out i
mean the data itself it's like while
there might be differences between men
and women and there might not be but the
empirical evidence suggests that
if you add all the personality
differences between men and women
together you can reliably discriminate
between who's a man and who's a woman
with women with about 75 percent
accuracy which is pretty accurate but
trait by trait men and women are more
alike than different so yeah fair enough
um and there are two dimensions where
the differences particularly manifest
themselves
sensitivity to negative emotion and
agreeableness and
and so that's that and
then those differences are bigger in
egalitarian countries than in
non-egalitarian countries which is
counter-intuitive and surprising and
shocking
and interesting
also holds true for dark triad
characteristics by the way so
psychopathy narcissism and
machiavellianism the gender gap is
larger in more egalitarian cultures
you may not be surprised to know that
but i found that pretty interesting i
mean it sort of falls in line with all
the other research you're describing
yeah it's very interesting that more
egalitarian policies magnify some
differences they ameliorate in
scandinavia the preferred age gap
between women and men is somewhat
smaller than in non-egalitarian
countries so there are some
there are some
phenomena that do
modify towards
equality with egalitarian social
policies but lots don't anyways i
started to get nervous about lecturing
about those sorts of things i i thought
geez i'm nervous about this isn't that
strange
and part of it was because i did have
some female students who came up to me
after lectures and who were
offended you know they were snippy and
and sarcastic and that very rarely
happened to me and so it was quite
marked
you know i'd have the odd hyper feminist
type stomp out of my first class
even a few years ago just as a you know
demonstration of sorts but that
that really meant nothing
but and then now my graduate students
started telling me that they were very
nervous about discussing anything to do
with sex differences and the women
particularly and and so that's that
started to become worrisome
so
and what do you see happening in in
cambridge what's it been like there for
you
i mean well
well really it's been it's been a very
strict lockdown over the last uh 15 plus
months or so
but before that it wasn't you know it
wasn't bad i was i was still fairly open
with my views uh you know i wrote i
defended uh you in an op-ed in the new
york times i've written you know the
luxury beliefs post i've i've not been
i've not necessarily withheld my views
um
fortunately within my department i
haven't had much of an issue i think the
psych department here is very solid um
but you know more broadly the culture
the campus culture is um
you know about the same as it is
anywhere else uh sort of um people are
people are afraid i had a conversation
with a professor here
last year i had lunch with him and he
it was interesting when he told me he
said that um it's not necessarily that
the faculty agree with a lot of the sort
of extreme political uh movements that
are going on but they just want to be
left alone um they just want to do their
work they just want to do the research
yeah and if a bunch of social mobs come
after them and say you know you better
sign this petition or you better say
this or you better post that they just
want to do it and and get get these
people out of their lives get it out of
their hair
and so they're not
they're not ideologues many of them
probably most of them are not but they
just want to sort of get back to their
lives and they'll just do whatever they
have to they're selected for that i mean
to become an academic
a research academic you have to be
obsessive about some
specialization
and you have to
wall yourself off from everything else
and pursue that because otherwise you're
not publishing your three papers a year
or whatever it requires to maintain your
academic status it takes a tremendous
amount of specialization and so
we set up universities to put up walls
around people who were willing to
specialize so they could do exactly that
but it's laid them open to invasion by
people who have a political agenda and
that's often failed researchers who
become administrators for example and
who are interested in
power which is pretty much what they
talk about all the time as well
and so i mean i've seen
faculty
are
in some sense powerless
by choice in some ways
against the kinds of demands that you're
describing but it's also a consequence
of the selection methods that produce
them to begin with and the purpose of
the university
i had a friend here uh who was very
active online on social media so he was
a graduate you know medical school
graduate who came here is against
cambridge scholar to do research and i
think biochemistry or something
and he posted something online about um
his views on on being a pro-life person
and
you know his phd supervisor and people
in his department were getting all kinds
of calls you know saying that they had
to let him go that they should fire him
uh they need to kick him out of
cambridge and so on and
you know they basically they didn't kick
him out but they told him like you have
to take down your social media account
because we just can't have people
constantly calling and emailing and
harassing and so on the activists just
make it so costly
to have an opinion that people just sort
of you know they sort of silence
themselves you know why why would you
want to get involved they just sort of
acquiesce to it not because they agree
but just because they don't want to have
to deal with the burden it's very it's i
mean it's a sort of clever strategy i
think on on the part of the activists
um
that's something that i'm interested in
too is just like who who tends to to be
attracted to those movements and how
effective they are i mean i've seen
academic papers retracted because um the
journal editor uh you know they posted
something like you know we had to
withdraw this paper because the journal
editor received credible threats of
physical violence like you can literally
threaten to kill the journal editor and
then they'll just take take out whatever
paper you want him to take out i mean
it's uh like it's very interesting to
see that this is this is uh the world
we're living in
yeah well it's no it's no joke to be
targeted like that and it's not
surprising it shuts people down
it's really hard i mean it's
understandable yeah i don't begrudge
anyone for for for doing it um a lot of
people don't
yeah they just don't have the stomach to
deal with with that level of of
notoriety or controversy um the way that
you and others have
yeah well it isn't obvious that i've
dealt with it either so i'm still here
but that's about all i'd say about it
it certainly hasn't been
it's been terrible i'm sorry i took your
personality test um
shortly after it it came out when you
still had the discount going and i
scored in the ninth percentile in
agreeableness um
so i think that might have something to
do with why i'm okay with with uh you
know sort of taking on some of this heat
yeah yeah well the thing about
disagreeable people is that they will
say what they think
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so was that compassion or
politeness
it was it was it was very low on
politeness and a little higher on
compassion but still like pretty low on
both
uh and it averaged out to the ninth
percentile so so at least i'm i'm you
know a little more compassionate than i
am polite
well one in 10 isn't you know isn't that
low really all things considered
so
but but that would explain that would
explain your willingness to take
confrontational positions or adversarial
positions let's say well obviously you
also believe that they're you know that
you're relating something that is true
so we don't know how much moral courage
it takes and what personality attributes
are
shaping the ability to
voice unpopular truths but i suspect
disagreeableness has something to do
with it
it's strange in my case because i'm very
agreeable as it turns out but
which is probably why i pay a high price
for doing it even though i do do it
so interesting
yeah i was uh yeah i mean i i'd gotten
in a lot of trouble in school as a kid i
um
yeah i just always had this sort of um
disposition
to uh to rebel and to question rules and
and so on and and fortunately over time
i was able to get it under control to
some extent i also scored pretty high in
conscientiousness which may be part of
why i was able to
land where i where i've landed but i you
know it was a long securities path to
get here
right yeah well conscientiousness is a
colder virtue but it tends to pay off in
the long run
so what do you think you're going to do
when you finish your degree you know you
said you're you're not that interested
in pursuing an academic path
yeah i well my book is supposed to come
out later next year so near the end of
next year and i'll probably be spending
a lot of time promoting that and
yeah i i don't know i do enjoy research
writing teaching all of those things so
in whatever capacity i can
continue to do that whether it's working
at a think tank
or or even just going full independent
and and sort of starting my own channel
or something like that um
and yeah i'll just be continuing writing
and and
sharing my views in one way or another
although i'm not exactly sure what form
that'll take
well it was really good talking with you
today i thought the discussion was
moved along at a great clip and uh i
appreciated your viewpoints and your
candor all of that and
i learned a fair bit as a consequence of
talking to you and so much appreciated
likewise thank you dr peterson you bet
you bet good to meet you maybe we'll
meet up in cambridge if i ever come
there
let's do it
[Music]
you